what about the hollywood sign getting
taken down you see can you pull that up
do you mind nick
did you see uh people talking about that
because obviously you know there's a lot
of been a lot of stuff people taking
down monuments you know yeah yeah
confederate flag people are taking down
you know i think the cleveland indians
just announced today they're gonna
change their name
um do you want me to look that up yeah
maybe both of you can i know you only
have two hands but uh
but i thought about so then part of me
like because i get a little bit angry
sometimes about like because confederate
flag i learned it from
dukes of hazard right right and that's
you like you have a whole different uh
understanding of it because you're a
southern guy
right i would just see it like now if
somebody rode by with a corr
like if somebody yelled the n word right
and was waving it right i'm like wrong
yeah that's a bad guy
but but i just start to worry just when
does it end you know like when does it
well
i think a lot of people think that
because a lot of people are like
at a certain point if you go through
history
oh yeah nobody's clean no nobody
nobody's clean so do you just
i mean every movie everything so do you
just get rid of everything do you
destroy everything and then you start
burning books and then you start
you're just heading that stage like i
don't really care about confederate
monuments but it's like
then it's like well let's get rid of uh
you know washington
right lincoln let's get rid of mount
rushmore it's like where does it end
and the other question nobody asks what
do you replace that with
right what are we replacing it with
right because you're going to lose a lot
of branding like even like the
university george washington university
right
like they've been thinking like okay do
we have to change has been like
yeah they just change it to gw and
nobody it's enough they'll be like it's
gw
it's like kfc when they were like not
using chicken
yeah it's kfc and you're like what does
that c stand for
they're like i don't know something
crunchy we don't know what it is
yeah it's just like i can't imagine
that anyone really cares that's the
thing that anybody
really cares because we grew up going
like we would go from mardi gras we
would go by the um
we would go by the everybody would meet
at the robert e lee statue in new
orleans right right
and everybody would meet there black
white right that's all we had we had a
little bit of like
i guess maybe mexican or china like kind
of like one person might have been a
pacific islander
yeah something yeah gotcha like like i
grew up in a town we had a group called
wham whites against mexicans right
yeah and we didn't have any mexicans so
they would always is that a musical
group
no this is not okay this is more of like
get the torch
yeah yeah just like a budget antifa you
know like antifa but that had to be home
by 6 p.m for dinner
gotcha okay and then and it was only
three guys in it
right and um and then they like kind of
attacked the chinese like semi-chinese
kid once like there was no
real follow-through you know but is it
because they couldn't find a mexican
yeah there was no let's just get let's
just get this guy he's
semi-changed totally yeah yeah oh my
brother it's the best we're gonna do we
just gotta
we gotta show people about it and
there's no mexicans around
but this guy looked half chinese yeah so
he's getting it yeah look
we drew it on our binders during lunch
this [ __ ] is real now yeah we gotta move
forward
yeah wow but yeah just start so then i
start to think okay well
yeah you tear it down but then here's
what i start to worry about is
say in certain uh in certain cities and
whether they be southern really or
anywhere because some of it starts to
branch out now to like oh well thomas
jefferson had slaves and
this person dated a black woman who was
underage and just different things where
it just keeps escalating
and it's like when does like at a
certain point
um yeah like you're saying it's going to
hit everybody but then the people who
live in those places
right who associate with that history
and don't associate it with it racially
right like and i know this is just a
white perspective but those people are
going to be like i don't want to live in
a place where
now the street that i'm on has been
changed like it's also like why are we
ignoring history why are we trying to
get rid of it
right why not just learn from it why not
appreciate it why not look at the statue
and go
yeah that guy did some [ __ ] like why
are statues only of good people
number one like the idea that every
statue it doesn't mean that i never look
at a statue and go that was a great guy
that guy was great i bet he was great i
never have ever looked at his stature
and went
i should think like him yeah yeah i look
at his statue and go that guy did
something maybe good maybe very bad
he might have been very bad but it was
significant that's what a statue is it's
about significance
it's not about moral purity right that
was the guy was a role player he like
throw up a carmelo anthony somewhere
yeah you know what i'm saying like
right he kind of he like people are 50
50 on if he's really that helpful to a
team
right you know right right but i i've
never looked at a statue
i don't know who we're infantilizing
people
yeah we're treating them like children
we're telling them oh if you walk by a
statue
you're going to automatically uh look at
that statue or that person in reverence
yeah that's not what does anyone care
you know they go let's take down the
christopher columbus statue in the
middle of columbus circle new york city
no one knows who that is right the kids
don't know who it is they don't give a
[ __ ] they don't give up they're on their
phone they don't even look at the statue
so the idea that like columbus uh it's
about
you know columbus is reinforcing
imperialism and genocide
no one cares nobody knows who he is well
then it's like should you take down like
because there's you know a lot of
artwork and i'm i don't know if there's
monuments but
of like slave probably like arriving in
like charleston like slave ships and
stuff that did
so then it's like well if you're a white
person you don't want to remember that
all the time
so it's like but you should have to look
at it you should have to be like man
wow a lot of this town was built by
slave labor
right that to me makes sense like you
have those monuments and you're like i
can't forget
this history right you know but if i i
feel like if you're going to apply
apply it to everything it's just like
you know because some people might think
man
i didn't do this right why do i have to
be reminded of it all the time yeah
but yeah because that's applying the
same psychology i feel like to the ones
where you're applying it to
you know like george washington or
robert e lee you know like yeah
or just put on robert lee's thing this
guy got second place in the civil war
that's right this guy was [ __ ] up
yeah this guy is [ __ ] up and aren't we
all and aren't we all
um or yeah i think it's it the people
that really are advocating
that they take down everything are
people that just
want to completely remake or reimagine
america
yeah so they start with the iconography
of it and they start with like
the statues and everything and it's like
we can all agree that america has some
deep deep flaws it should be corrected
but
i don't think anybody's or a lot of
people are not going to be on board
for the new version of america that a
lot of these people want
right nobody wants that where you don't
have any freedom
well nobody really wants that and i
think that's what
this kind of america that they envision
is in america where
everybody is constantly policing
themselves and their speech and you're
being
their surveillance of everything you
write
and say and it's just weird like you
want to rat on people and if
i remember when gronin started people
were like yo
go go call this number if these kids
don't have masks i'm like what
yeah i don't want to be a rat dude
there's a kid skateboarding i'm
supposed to call a number and be like
yeah i see a kid without a mess go get
him
yeah todd has it yeah yeah i don't want
to inform on people
i just that to me that whole world is
not
i don't like that world i don't want to
live in that world i'd rather live in
the world
with some of the problems in this
orwellian
nightmarish world where like people are
like i can't say anything
i'm afraid to have an opinion i'm afraid
to meet somebody at this corner because
both of the people it's named after were
racist yeah it's just like what are we
doing
because then it's just people wandering
around yeah unable to meet at certain
intersections they don't know what it
means or the weird guy who will only
meet
in front of the robert e lee statue he's
like we're meeting in front of lee
you want to date me we meet in front of
lee and that's
it we always meet in front of a
confederate monument yeah
yeah it's weird man or just yeah or
maybe like you add
to the mind now i think that would be
even a better idea yeah
add to the monuments yeah you know yeah
how are you kicking them in the face yes
dude how are you telling me doing the
scissor kick right something sitting on
the front of the horse
why not it's funny i think it's like in
the absence of real solutions people are
like hey let's just take the statue down
yeah you know it's like how about
stopping police shooting black people
yeah uh let's take the statue down
how about stopping uh some of the the
issues in hollywood people getting
abused or whatever
let's just take the sign down yeah let's
just take the sign down
everything but see that's where it's
like that to me would really make
hollywood i think if you took the sign
down yeah then hollywood's going to be
like well what do we have then
right what what was the movement to take
the hollywood sign down i haven't heard
about that well oh sorry nick headed up
a second ago and i uh
wait a minute can you go back to indiana
governor wait a minute hold on go back
to the
indiana governor says all people over
the age of aids will face wait a minute
this is great what was that indiana
governor says all people over the age of
eight
will face a face mask mandate there are
some nine year olds that are gonna get
thrown into paddy wagons and that in
indiana
oh what are you ten yeah get your mask
on
yeah i love kids learning about
government at nine
you know being like oh i lose my
freedoms at nine
so different dude damn and are these
kids
and i just wonder if the masks
how are they gonna develop their
their world they're it's gonna be
underdeveloped yeah i mean
we're headed under yeah developed
i mean we're heading to a scary place
i'm all for like yeah where the mask
keeps
people safe whatever but i just think
there's something hilarious
about the like this weird age of like
eight yeah
this like meaningless distance that's
when they know eight yeah
it's like if you're nine you better have
your [ __ ] together yeah
you better have your [ __ ] together at
nine it's almost like the 1800 it's like
the freaking age
yeah yeah you're gonna serve in a war uh
the hollywood sign it says right here
the hollywood sign
um has been through some stuff it said
on there
did you have an art was there something
i have there was one tweet it
is
people that are on the right they're
going if you're going to take down
jefferson washington we're going to take
down a hollywood site so this is what
happens
it just becomes and that makes sure
i get it and that's when you start to
look because that's what i feel like
it's like
you have to that's smart ball to me
yeah if you are on the right or if you
are
it's like well what about the the you
know the obvious
you know the the me too so what about
all the [ __ ] that goes on in hollywood
100 percent deviant place
100 it's awesome 100 percent yeah but
it's risque
yeah there's lots of long
established problems yeah power dynamic
issues here oh yeah um
but the whole thing is like i when jenny
slate uh apologized for doing the voice
of a mixed race character on big mouth
yeah i saw that i did this whole thing
on my podcast as a joke where i was like
it's not enough that she's stepping down
because her apology is very creepy right
people i was like why why does she jenny
slate from everything i know about her
is probably not like a racist right
why is she coming out to like confess
she's like i've erased black people
i cannot believe and it was very weird
like she felt she had to come out and
give this
big explanation it was very weird so i
just said
you know to counter the insanity of that
i said that's not enough she should go
to jail
yeah she should be in jail you know i
think she should go to jail
i saw this every day jenny slate is not
in jail i will speak out
yeah and that's the whole thing because
i said it's not enough so this
is what you kind of do when people go
woke you
just go further right you go
you go wide awake yeah yeah you go real
yeah wide awake you go to insomnia yeah
you go put her in jail
yeah put her in check not enough and who
are her parents where are they living
and where are they let's share this
we're burning that house you raised a
racist
yeah get them let's share their
information and what that's supposed to
do is make people go oh yeah this is
stupid yeah
but as a matter of fact you get people
on twitter going i don't think she
should go to jail and then some people
go
maybe like a re-education
if you're like yeah maybe like some type
of re-education or something but not
jail next you know she has to take 40
hours of school
driving from african-american
instructors yeah what's great is like
i'm like oh you're almost there like
you're almost at my crazy example
right you're almost at let's put her in
jail yeah that's what you see when you
tweet something crazy
and the responses are like yeah that
might make some sense you're like what
yeah i tweeted the other day and i said
i walked into a grocery store
and i uh they told me to wear a mask i
took it off uh i i didn't have a mask on
i faked a seizure
and then i ran around the store uh uh
called this uh screaming the storm is
coming
and a lot of people on twitter were like
good for you man i wish i could have
seen
that like dead serious like yeah you
show them
i'm like yeah i was i didn't do any of
that right but people are like yeah you
show them
people are ready well people are looking
also for
anything that's against the norm so
that's why another reason why i think a
lot of what you say really kind of
stands out like a lot of times because
it's like
also i think you're finding like a seam
of humor in this yeah where sometimes i
forget to like
just be light about like just like joke
around about stuff
well because like you watch these shows
now that are like you know ellen and
fallon they're all at their kitchen
tables
yeah like jimmy kimmel's in his living
room and you're like what's going on
it's weird and then they're interviewing
people
and they're interviewing celebrities and
they're talking about movies coming out
and you're like this is so dystopian
yeah like it's so disconnected from the
reality
that i think people just want anybody
whether you're crazy or not
yeah to talk about something that's
actually going on right
the reality something that's actually
happening good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you could watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah